Have you listened to our Stephen A Smith
impersonator I never have but I've been
anxious to hear it I've never heard it
you called me and said I understand you
have a Stephen A Smith impersonator I
said I said Stephen I think this guy's
really good okay uh you told me you were
going to listen you did not I did not I
apologize I've been would you be willing
I know it's 9:00 and you have to get out
of here but for one minute would you
speak to Stephen A Smith impersonator I
want to hear this guy imitate me this is
Stephen A Smith I might as well call me
Stephen B Smith all right Stephen B what
do you want to say to Stephen A you know
what Stephen a first of all I agree with
you when you were talking about the fans
of the Dallas Cowboys I mean I was
living what was going on I mean I mean
love was busting that living you know
what and I'm talking about the Cowboys
they was literally getting their ass
kicked out there I mean I I couldn't
believe it but what I want to debate
with you about is you said Lamar Jackson
is going to win the Super Bowl I totally
don't agree with you there's no way
Lamar Jackson beats Patrick Mahomes and
he got Travis Kelsey and he's got those
googly ass potato it's not going to
happen what do you think of that Stephen
A not bad not bad I don't know about
googly eyes I don't use that word googly
eyes I don't know about that uh but but
he he's pretty good he's pretty good I
like him what give him a a grade of uh
ABC D B+ B+ B+ I'll take it B+ I'll take
B+ I mean if I'm getting a B+ that's
right up there with Jay Ferrell and
Jamie Fox he used googly eyes instead of
blasphemous
yes BL all right that's right howy you
stay off the
weed n that that that's a a minus that
elevates to a a
minus that's what I'm talking
about